ハワイに行きたいこんにちははじめちゃったよね皆さん家に鍵ついてますでしょうか
のた分逆に鍵がない家の方が少ないと思うんですよね特になんかアパートとか
一人暮らしの部屋と例えば外側ですよ
家の外側だったら先をさせてガチャってアクティブに家の内側からだったらこう罪
みたいな増加って愚痴ったら開く
または閉じるというのがいい
一般的な形だと思うんですけどもそこで私
思いついてしまった外から内側でも開け閉めができるということはこれすなわち無限の
可能性があるどころか増えたわけでございますというわけで今回なドアがべきを開けて
もうわーや永源寺開かないドッキリ
やっていこうと思いますまあやり方はいたってシンプルですなぜかが外に行ってて帰っ
てきます
家の鍵がかかっているので外側から鍵を起こさしてドアの鍵を
開けると秋ノートと does タイミングで僕が内側から開けられ卓球を瞬時に
かける強い子みたいなってガーンッ同じタイミングで相手に悟られなければ大丈夫だと
思います
こういうことで外から入ってきた人間は鍵を開けたはずなの味がしまっているそう
さっきボスまさにキュア日
鍵を開けても開けても
一向に開かない最強の動画完成すると思われますというわけでさっそくやっていきま
しゃべ by が
かもよ
よし寿司ませんはいちょっとお願いがあるんですけど廃コンビニってコーラ買ってきて
もらっていいですか
1本 si bon エロスポニーエプロン大丈夫そうです
[拍手]
色いますはい p
いい一番だった
[拍手]
ん
分
クリーンん
ふぅふぅ
準備完了ですさあこれで今書かせる鍵は交通なので彼が帰ってきてから今書を戻す瞬間
に動かするに
戻す彼は何度鍵を開けても開けるどう探しベル動作に変わってしまう
追い詰められるとき
これはある
どうするでしょうか
[音楽]
の
ん
[音楽]
ああああああいいいいいいいいいい
ああああああん
うわぁ
me me she
てなんかねえなんかじゃないなと思う
実は安藤を
開けても開けてももうドアが開かれになってるだけなんですけどこそ開けるペースが速
すぎ
がかかるか乱されてしまった
re ん
なんでしんない
下の方があると思ううん
ブーツ
かけてねーやキッキングスピード勝負なん
ています
ん
あああああった
ああああああああ
4日
[音楽]
ああああああん
の
いいいい
[音楽]
ああああああん
おっん
あったおます
dee dee
[音楽]
ん
くっ
[音楽]
me
teal
ana あああっ
さああぶねー何
いやドアを開けた負ければかなりところです